avec plus de 6000 demandes de
dédommagements ça c'est six fois plus
que d'habitude
la crue printanière de 2017 s'avère être
la plus coûteuse en indemnités pour le
gouvernement du québec
[Musique]
jusqu'à présent le gouvernement a versé
près de 156 millions de dollars à
l'ensemble des sinistrés québécois mais
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que presque
tout l'argent est allé aux victimes du
débordement de la rivière des outaouais
et du lac des deux montagnes
les résidents et non des de la
municipalité de pontiac par exemple ont
reçu un peu plus de 5 millions de
dollars et la somme gonfle plus on
descend la rivière gatineau est
clairement la plus touchée près de 45
millions de dollars ont été versés en
indemnités
jusqu'à maintenant québec a distribué
plus de 11 millions de dollars aux
citoyens de rigaud et un autre hans
millions de dollars à ceux de deux
montagnes et comme toute cette eau a
fait déborder le lac des deux-montagnes
lui-même des centaines de résidences et
de commerces ont été endommagés dans
l'ouest de laval et de l'île de montréal
la facture est de 13 millions $ à laval
et notre 33 millions $ à montréal
c'est d'ailleurs parce qu'elle a touché
des zones très peuplées que
d'inondations l'an dernier ont coûté si
cher à ces de comparaison la crue
printanière de 2010 être a coûté trois
fois plus cher que l'inondation de la
vallée du richelieu en 2011 qui avait
elle coûté environ 50 millions de
dollars au trésor québécois et la
facture les inondations l'an dernier n'a
pas fini d'augmenter
il ya encore des dizaines de familles
qui n'ont pas été indemnisés et québec
devra encore versé de l'argent à ceux et
celles qui sont actuellement en train de
compléter leurs travaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]